حلقه جديده ضمن مسلسل التوتر في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه منسوب الاحتقان يواصل
لارتفاع مع مرور الايام اسراب من الطائره
العسكريه تحلق في سماء المنطقه رسائل
متبادله
بينك لكن بلغه المناورات والصواريخ كوريا
الجنوبيه ارسلت عشرات المقاتلات الشبح الى
الجو انهاء طائرات مقاتله متطوره بعد رصد
180 طائره حربيه كوريا الشماليه تحلق في
ارضها فيما يبدو استعراضا للقوه هيئه
الاركان المشتركه لكوريا الجنوبيه قالت ان
الطائره الحربيه الكوريه الشماليه تم
رصدها في مناطق مختلفه داخل البلاد وعلى
طول السواحل الشرقيه والغربيه لكنها لم
تقترب بشكل خاص من الحدود بين الكوريتين
فاي من هذه الطائرات لم تدخل خط العمل
التكتيكيكي خط تم تحديده من 20 الى 50
كيلومترا شمال الحدود البريه والبحريه
للكوريتين لاغراض المراقبه لاعطاء الجنوب
بوقتا كافيا للرد على الاستفزازات او
الهجمات
التدريبات الجويه لكوريا الجنوبيه جاءت
بعد اختبار جالتها الشماليه اطلاق حوالي
30 صاروخا باليستيا خلال اليومين السابقين
بما في ذلك صاروخ بالستي عابر للقارات في
رد غاضب على تدريبات القوات الجويه
المشتركه بين واشنطن وصول لتتواصل مظاهر
استعراض القوه بين الجزئين الشقيقين في
تطور ينذر باندلاع حرب بينهما مثل ما حدث
في زمن الماضي
العربي العربيه